the kobit 19 pandemic isn't slowing down
and there is only one hope to end it a
vaccine
but news of russia granting regulatory
approval to a covit 19 vaccine
has been received with
i skepticism that the russians have
actually definitively proven
that the vaccine is safe and effective i
seriously doubt
that they've done that and what about
the other scientists across the world
what's their research showing and when
will they be ready
[Music]
welcome to your kobit 19 special here on
dw news i'm monica jones and villain as
always good to have you with us
now normally it takes years to develop a
new vaccine
but in times of this pandemic it can't
go fast enough
not only in russia here's a quick look
at where we're at
a little pinprick but it brings high
hopes with it
inside the syringe a vaccine from the
kyravac company
it's designed to imitate the coronavirus
in the body to provoke an immune
response
about 200 people have volunteered to
take part in the trial
this way i can do my bit to help defeat
the virus
ten companies in germany are currently
working to defeat the virus by
developing vaccines
two are already testing their vaccines
on humans
trials generally consist of three
clinical phases
phase one is mainly focused on whether
the human body can tolerate
the vaccine and the reaction of the
immune system
phase 2 looks at how high the dosage has
to be
and phase 3 tests effectiveness whether
the vaccine offers protection in
everyday life
normally approval takes about eight to
ten years
but now the process is supposed to go
much faster
here at the university of tubingen
hospital phase one is nearing its end
from the data so far we can see that the
vaccine is well tolerated and safe
and we also hope that the first signals
of the immune defense which are becoming
apparent
are also positive
another german is already testing its
vaccine on humans
beyond tech based in the german city of
mainz
is partnering with the us pharmaceutical
company pfizer
they're already combining phases two and
three testing whether the vaccine
actually protects against coronaviruses
in everyday life
beyondtech has around 30 000 volunteer
test subjects worldwide
it hopes to have an approved vaccine
before the end of the year
the head of germany's medical regulatory
body thinks germany is on the right
track
german vaccine developers are well
advanced they're in a global premier
league
these are modern platform technologies
for vaccines i expect that even two
vaccines could possibly come from
germany
if there are more so much the better
a vaccine for everyone by early next
year that's an ambitious goal
that will require a lot more pinpricks
well other countries are even more
ambitious in india
even the government is pushing hard for
quick results
the threat of another serious lockdown
has people worried
but indian researchers are hard at work
trying to find an
answer in the form of a vaccine once a
vaccine is here that things should
improve it's
this it should it would also give us
consolation on many fronts it's
it's a it's a reassuring thing things
would be better at least
you won't be that scared walking out in
public and maybe
you won't have to wear the mask all the
time in july
two indian vaccine candidates initiated
phase one human trials
doses will be administered to volunteers
spread over a dozen sites
the indian government says it feels it
has a moral imperative
to develop the vaccine and many major
indian pharmaceutical brands
are eager to oblige 60
of the vaccines supplied in the world
whether it be africa or europe or
southeast asia or anywhere are of indian
origin
so india is perceived
and is an important player in the
vaccines
for supply for the world this pressure
however
took a political turn india's top
medical research body in a letter to
trial sites
said that the trials should be expedited
to have the vaccine ready to launch by
mid-august
this raised serious concerns on whether
these extraordinarily expedited trials
will be safe and ethical the move was
seen by critics as a way for the indian
prime minister
to make a dramatic announcement in his
independence day speech on august 15th
rallying on a cry that india can be
self-reliant
but after pressure from medical
community the government body clarified
that no compromises would be made on
safety
and that the deadline was simply to
expedite the trials and
cut through red tape in reality though
researchers say that it could take close
to a year for the first two phases of
the indian vaccine trials to be
completed
well so far there's been no vaccine
which has gone through such a rapid
development cycle
you know the earliest any vaccine is
taken is at least a few years if 11
third
of any vaccine candidate in any country
which promises a two-month
r d cycle and being ready for public use
in two months but with close to a fifth
of the world's population
india is seen as crucial to test the
efficacy of any corporate vaccine
the rapidly rising burden of the disease
and the intent to be self-reliant
raises the stakes even further
and for more i'm joined by zikri trum
manager of
research development and innovation of
the vfa that's the german association of
research-based pharmaceutical companies
good to have you with us
so we just see in india is rushing to
get a vaccine but russia
has actually just announced that it's
approved the world's first kovit 19
vaccine it'll start inoculating the
country's teachers and medical staff
what do you make of that is that the big
breakthrough we've been waiting for
i don't think that's a big breakthrough
because it's a
matter of how high you are setting the
requirements for such a registration
in the eu for example you would not get
at this point of development of the
russian
vaccine marketing authorization here for
the eu
certainly what's missing what's missing
as far as we know says up to now
no data from a phase three trial and
this
is a requirement an absolute requirement
here
what is important about the phase three
trial
phase three trials are necessary
to assess the both efficacy
and the safety of a medicine this is a
big trial with
many thousands of participants
of different age for example with
different comorbidities
there should be people in who had
already had
a covet infection and of course those
who had not
and you need many thousands of people to
show
that your vaccine is really safe
and efficient and that's why it normally
takes uh eight to ten years to develop a
new vaccine as we've heard in in the
other report uh but now with copied 19
we certainly see that
researchers across the world in china
and india and even companies here in
europe that they say that they might
have a vaccine
by the end of this year so that's very
fast how is that possible
yes it's very fast but there are several
reasons
why this development could be so fast
first one is we have a good experience
with
the precessor of saskoff 2
that is with saskoff 1. at that time
there had been some vaccines in
development and
some of these vaccines have gone through
to face two
trials so there are much excess much
much experience for getting a vaccine
for
saskoff too the other reason is
meanwhile new platform technologies
which are much faster than
the old-fashioned development techniques
and the last thing is that both in the
companies
and within the regulatory bodies
highest priority have such developments
and there's a very good cooperation here
between the regulators and industry
people
to get the development done as fast as
possible
so dr trum just very briefly uh based
on the fact that we might get a vaccine
sooner than normally when are you ready
to get vaccinated
i am ready to get vaccinated as soon as
our regulatory agency in europe systema
in
amsterdam has given the green light to
such a vaccine i
rely i trust here in our agencies we
have seen
within the past years that they are
doing a very good job
and they have assured that they will
only
give approval to vaccines which are
really safe and efficacious
thank you so much
well time now for your questions and
that means it's over to our science
correspondent derek williams
how can a cytokine storm be stopped if
it has started
cytokines are are signaling molecules
that are released by immune cells and
they're involved in
inflammation which is is part of the
body's immune response to the invasion
of a pathogen but in cobit 19 patients
who deteriorate the checks
and balances in the immune system can
stop
working correctly and and the immune
cells continue to churn out
cytokines on mass even when they're no
longer
needed then this this huge wave of
cytokines begins attacking the body's
healthy tissues as well as infected
tissue and this sort of
feedback loop called called a cytokine
storm
which in in many cases can be the
primary cause of mortality
um there are drugs out there for toning
down the immune system response that
that could be effective
at preventing an impending cytokine
storm in a patient
like the corticosteroid dexamethasone
but it's a fairly blunt instrument that
affects the immune response
as a whole several much more specific
cytokine inhibitors
that have been approved for other
conditions like arthritis
are currently in testing to see whether
they are also effective
in coronavirus induced cytokine storms
there's also a machine that actively
filters cytokines out of a patient's
blood
many times in the course of a day but
it's still
in in clinical testing
you